this breaking news an hour before I came
on a that Benjamin Netanyahu has
categorically dismissed hamas's new
calls for a prolonged ceasefire in Gaza
pledging to forge a ha with Israel's
military campaign until securing what he
terms as total Victory Netanyahu pledged
to destroy Hamas and ruled out any
Arrangement that leaves a Palestinian
militant group in full or partial
control of Gaza I would like to
emphasize once again there is no other
solution other than this complete and
decisive victory because otherwise it is
just a matter of time till the next
Massacre and the access of Terror from
Iran will continue so only by destroying
Hamas will we have security for the
state of Israel in the north and in the
South because Hamas would like to
radiate its Terror all over the Middle
East what J to discuss this is the
Israeli American journalist Trader the
Israeli American activist and author mik
pelled and the Palestinian commentator
Omar bad well welcome to all of you um
start with you Emily uh a lot of people
around the world imploring Israel to
have some kind of ceasefire not least to
get the hostages are but also to stop
the Relentless killing of uh innocent
Palestinians women children and so on
but Netanyahu absolutely adamant uh
tonight no deal no ceasefire we will go
on until Hamas are completely finished
what is your reaction to
this well first of all thanks for having
me on this important topic tonight I
think the way that even the sentiment
was phrased that it's Israel rejecting
ceasefire isn't quite accurate you know
when it comes to what the situation is
on the ground Israel has been willing to
accept multiple ceasefires in the past
as well as they have done temporary
pauses in fighting um the reality is
that we had a ceasefire on October 6th
it wasn't Israel who started this war
um but it is Israel who will finish it
and you cannot invade The Sovereign
borders we're not even talking about
disputed territory we're not talking
about the West Bank but the Sovereign
borders of the state of Israel rape
murder and maim innocent people and then
kidnap over 200 more and expect that you
can dictate the terms of your own
Survival and staying in power in the
Gaza Strip This is just not the way it
works and Israel would actually be in
violation of international law for doing
so because Israel as a state Act has an
obligation legally to restore a sense of
security to the citizens of the state of
Israel and unfortunately that cannot be
done until Hamas is removed from power
in the Gaza Strip well mik I can see you
laughing there incredulously before you
respond to that I just want to inform
viewers about what the Hamas proposed
deal was as seen by the Reuters news
agency phase one a 45-day pause in
fighting during which all Israeli women
hostages is males under 19 the elderly
and sick would be exchanged for
Palestinian women and children held in
Israeli jails Israeli forces would
withdraw from populated areas of Gaza
and the Reconstruction of hospitals and
refugee camps would begin phase two
remaining male Israeli hostages would be
exchanged for Palestinian prisoners and
Israeli forces would leave Gaza
completely phase three both sides would
exchange remains and bodies and Hamas is
also calling for the complete withdrawal
of Israeli forces from Gaza going
forward um your response to Netanyahu
saying No
Deal oh mik M I'm sorry I think you're
muting you're on mute at the moment if
you wouldn't mind just unmuting yourself
yes you're back well it seem it seems
certainly that the Hamas proposal is
reasonable that Nano being a genocidal
Maniac who wants to continue the killing
and the Bloodshed is not interested I
mean I think we've seen that the last
several months of of of his policies in
Gaza have led to what can only be
described as mass genocide and since the
entire world is standing with him and
he's not seeing any he's not facing any
consequences seriously there's no reason
for him to stop and so the question is
will the International Community step in
and force him to stop the killing force
him to accept the Hamas or the the
Palestinian proposals uh and will the
International Community stand by the
Palestinians who are now like I said
presented uh the world and presented
Israel with a very reasonable um a very
reasonable proposal for ceasefire having
said that I think the ceasefire is
nowhere nearly enough I think I I think
the entire International Community needs
to come in and and declare a no fly zone
over Gaza and and impose severe
sanctions against the state of Israel
particularly now since it's obvious that
he's the is the state of Israel is
refusing even a very reasonable proposal
by uh by the Palestinians by the
Palestinian representatives in in the
Gaza Strip so it seems very very clear
the only question is why is the
International Community not standing
with the Palestinians and not helping
the Palestinians to enforce at least
this very reasonable um proposal okay
but to play devil's advocate here
Israel's position is that Hamas
committed an appalling terror attack on
October the 7th killing over 1,200
people uh many of whom were innocent
women and children butchered in the most
Savage Manner and they have publicly
stated since then Hamas that they will
do the same thing again and again and
again if they're able to and at the
moment depending on which figures you
you look at at least half the Hamas
fighting force is still there and still
fighting um representing to Israelis an
existential threat to their very
existence so why should Netanyahu in
that circumstance allow half of Hamas to
continue to exist and and present that
threat to his
people well the question is why why
we're accepting the the Israeli premise
to this Israel has been engaged in
genocide and apartheid policies for 75
years Palestinians have been living
under a reign of terror particularly in
the Gaza Strip this is not the first
time that Israel massacred civilians by
the thousands in the Gaza Strip so why
Palestinians are resisting and why
Palestinian Fighters came out of Gaza on
October 7th and and and engaged in
resistance is not the question there not
resistance is it was what is what is
resistance about raping and murdering
and kidnapping innocent
civilian hyoc
murdering murdering children on the
street right to talk about killing
children Israel has no right to talk
about in the first place Israel do you
believe that Israel has a right to exist
in the first Israel has been massacring
children you
believe hang on let me to talk about the
let me interrupt
what to let me inter let me interrupt
because CH pleas with respect Mr pet let
me interrupt to say one member of the
panel hasn't spoken yet and has kept
very quiet respectfully during that uh
exchange between the two of you Omar
badan this this cuts to the quick of the
story really if you view what Hamas did
on October the 7th as simply
resistance then to me you are ignoring
the reality that it was an paing terror
attack you can have absolutely
legitimate concerns about the scale of
Israel's response I have them myself but
do you genuinely also believe that it
was resistance what happened that day
I'll I'll get to that in a minute but I
do have to respond first to the Gaul of
somebody invoking the killing of
children in light of Israel having
killed nearly 12,000 pal Palestinian
children buried under the rubble over
the past three months in a genocidal
scale in violence against against
defenseless children it's it's is
utterly and completely absurd and the
second and equally important point to
make is that anybody who tells you that
there was a ceasefire on October 6th was
lying to you on October 6 Palestinians
had no Freedom whatsoever throughout the
Gaza Strip they could not go in and out
of Gaza no airport no sea port no jobs
no access to the outside world no
functioning electricity and Israel
continued to steal Palestinian land in
the West Bank throughout that entire
year and for decades frankly even before
that and had killed nearly 250
Palestinians in the course of just the
beginning of the year until October 6th
so people who call that a ceasefire are
basically telling you to accept a status
quo in which Palestinians can be
murdered they can have their children
thrown in military detention
indefinitely in which Palestinian land
can be taken away from them at will and
they can be denied freedom and that's an
acceptable status quo so long as
Israelis are safe there's a word for
that kind of world and that's called
apartheid that is the current status quo
that always existed leading up to the
violence that we saw on October 7th now
certainly anytime that you engage in
violence against civilians that is
completely indefensible and there's no
way to excuse that nonetheless thinking
people look at the situation that led up
to it and understand that imprisoning
Palestinians by the Millions for no
crime other than being Palestinian in
Gaza and allowing and denying them
access to the outside world uh is
essentially a recipe to create a wave of
violence that is effectively inevitable
people who are serious about wanting to
end violence and serious about producing
a situation in which there is peace for
both Israelis and Palestinians have to
be concerned about the driving force of
that violence and the driving force is
absolutely Israeli apartheid that has
denied Palestinians freedom for too long
and until you solve that underlying
problem you're never going to get into a
situation in which there is any safety
or security for any you know you
continue you continue using all these
buzzwords aarth genocide and those
aren't what those words actually mean
but I do want to clarify a few things
that you commented on and the
I shouldn't be speaking about killing
children there is a massive difference
between a defensive War targeting
terrorist targets that are using
civilian fights including un schools
including hospitals in dangering their
own people in the Gaza Strip something
that they themselves have admitted and
the invading of The Sovereign borders of
a foreign country and murdering children
in their home on let me ask
not a defensive
War over
other let me ask Emily a question and
it's this Emily look I think Israel had
a right to defend itself a duty to
defend itself but we now have as we've
heard I think it's 12,000 children
believed to have been killed uh another
20,000 or so have been orphaned uh
2third of Gaza has been flattened and
here Benjamin Netanyahu says after four
months well we're nowhere near finished
there's months more of this we will
continue until the last Hamas terrorist
is gone okay but that may mean the
entire Gaza Strip is gone destroyed
flattened it may mean well hang on it
may mean the number of children killed
doubles to 20,000 maybe 30,000 at what
point does this become even to people
who support Israel imp placa about this
does it become just utterly
disproportionate well I think
proportionality isn't the actual
question here there's a very easy way to
end this war and that is to return all
of the hostages and to surrender
unconditionally that is what hamash
should be doing that is where the focus
PR hang on Emily that
would no hang on Benjamin Netanyahu
stated unequivocally this goes on until
Hamas are finished all of them that
means another that means another 20,000
people have to be killed right who are
just the terrorists so he's not going to
stop if the hostages got released
tomorrow that's not true I said unal
uncal of Hamas I don't think prime
minister Netanyahu has any intention
even if the hostages get returned
tomorrow of letting 20,000 Hamas
terrorists remain in power in Gaza he's
going to continue but that's I already
said that I said the release of hostages
and the unconditional surrender of Hamas
Hamas cannot remain in power in the Gaza
Strip and restore have Israel rest a
sense of security those two things
cannot coexist that is why Netanyahu
said we will not accept any term in
which Hamas stays in power because they
will do the same thing again and the
longer this goes on the longer they stay
in power the more funding I think the
most recent documents said 150 million
went through senoir in the documents
that the
IDF the more money that Iran is funding
you cannot just stronger Hamas is you
cannot just kill everybody in Gaza you
can't Israel is not intending to kill
everyone in Gaza
they carry on for many more months they
carry on for many more months how many
people are going to get killed no I
can't answer that question as to how
many people are going to be killed but I
can tell you that not a single uh not
even one more person would be killed if
Hamas surrendered unconditionally
today can I suggest something I make a
suggestion since nahu and his government
have before October 7th have already and
and previous Israeli governments have
murdered more civilians than Hamas ever
did why don't we do why don't we flip
this equation and say that the hostages
will be released once nanyo and his
government are taken to the Haag and and
and uh and charged with war crimes I
think it makes much more sense the
Israelis have killed far more
Palestinian children and Palestinian
civilians than Hamas or any Palestinians
ever have Israeli attacks on Gaza
preceded Hamas by decades Israeli
attacks the West Bank go on Israeli
attacks in Jerusalem go on where where
Hamas is not in charge so I mean this
whole Hamas excuse is ridiculous why we
do this let's wait till let's wait till
we remove nany's government and then
negotiate I think that should be the
condition and the Israeli military which
is a genocidal terrorist organization is
disarmed and dismantled that will be a
good time okay let me let me final let
me give the final word to the
Palestinian on the panel which is you
Omar look we have to be stop this
pretense that Israel is engaging in
accidental violence in which Palestinian
civilians are killed every major human
rights organization in the world
including by the way Israeli human
rights organizations document that the
Israeli military is engaging in
indiscriminate violence against
civilians and that is why the
international court of justice has found
that there is actually a plausible Case
for Israel being engaged in genocidal
violence in Gaza and that should tell
you something and we have to stop
pretending that you can kill this many
people on accident and just one issue
with with something that you mentioned
Piers I don't think this is a question
of proportionality we have to be clear
about what Israel is doing here this is
not an act of self-defense because an
occupier can never in principle be
defending themselves against the people
they're occupying if we are serious once
again what Israel is doing in Gaza if
they wanted self-defense there were zero
there were zero Israelis in Gaza on
October 6
zero Gaza they bombed it at will
whenever they wanted to and they
prevented
pal you never mention EGP no
responsibility
everything is always Israel you know you
know the problem the problem with that
argument the problem with that argument
is this is that when it wanted to at the
start of this war Israel had the power
and capability to turn off the energy
into Gaza to turn off the internet to
turn off the water to turn off the food
supply that is a form of occupation even
if you're not physically inside Gaza
that's actually false
defending
of I don't think Israel should have that
power over any Palestinian if Israel if
Israel was interested terorist
organization should be ruling
Palestinians either I don't think that I
agree with you is ring Israel I agree
with you I agree with you nuclear poers
ruling is okay listen I've got to bring
it I've got to bring it to an end it was
a good it was a good debate thank you
I've got to leave it there I'm sorry
we've run out of time we've gone longer
than than I was expecting to I
appreciate the passion on all sides I
hope we can get to a point where this
ends and and people stop dying I think
we can all agree with that so thank you
all of you for joining me I appreciate
it